- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
- No.
No, I can't, no.
- [Mark] Why not?
- No, I'm good.
I'm good.
- [Mark] Do you talk to your family?
- No.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- [Mark] Do you have an
abscess on your left arm?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay.
We're not getting much.
All right, so TJ.
- Yep.
- [Mark] Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Ohio,
a small town.
- [Mark] How long have you been out here?
- Two and 1/2, three years.
- [Mark] What brought you out here?
- Well, the guy I was with,
we caught a case in Ohio,
and he got out and came down here,
so I followed him.
Plus the drugs are easy here, yeah.
- [Mark] So that was possession in Ohio?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And where are
you sleeping out here?
Wherever.
- Yeah, usually tent to tent,
I had one, but.
- [Mark] You look pretty clean
for somebody who's going tent to tent.
- Yeah, I try not to
look like the people--
- [Mark] You don't.
- Yeah.
It's easy not to look like that.
- [Mark] Well, you got the showers down.
- Yeah, it's like,
go get up and take a shower.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood,
what did your childhood look like?
- Okay, so, pretty much growing up,
it was just me for a little bit,
and then my mom got
pregnant with my brother.
And my stepdad was the biggest coke dealer
in our small town,
so we had everything we wanted
but the cops were always
raiding our place.
They'd throw in the flash bombs
and everything would be all bright,
we couldn't see shit,
and then our stepdad, my dad,
his dad was on the floor,
arrested and shit.
And then we went through
that for like six years,
and my mom was a big alcoholic
so she used to beat me all the time.
Pretty much I started raising my brother
because she quit paying attention to us.
- [Mark] You started what your brother?
- Raising my brother.
- [Mark] Oh, raising your brother.
- Yeah, and so my mom,
there'd be different guys in and out.
And some of them,
a couple of times they kinda started,
they would hit on me,
and when I started getting older.
And a couple,
one time I woke up
and one of my mom's boyfriends
was in the bed with me and shit,
and that was weird, you know what I mean?
- [Mark] How old were you then?
- Probably 13, yeah.
And then my mom got back with my stepdad
after he got out of prison,
and shit started getting weird then too.
I caught him filming me
when I was taking a shower,
shit like that.
And that fucked me up
because that was supposed to be my dad.
My real dad lives in Pennsylvania,
he's cool and all,
but I don't know,
I don't talk to him.
My mom just died two years ago,
she OD'ed on heroin,
but she didn't even do heroin,
so her boyfriend got
involuntary manslaughter.
My brother's 19 now,
I don't really know,
my childhood was just fucked up,
that my house was a party house.
Everybody came there to party,
you know what I mean?
Growing up, I had to clean up needles
and I had to clean up beer
bottles and shit like that,
you know what I mean, so?
- [Mark] How old are you?
- [TJ] I just turned 25 in April.
I don't know.
- [Mark] What do you do for money?
- [TJ] See guys.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's
typically over the night,
during the night?
- [TJ] Yeah, because the daytime's slow.
You know what I mean?
But when I first got here,
I look better now than what I did
because I was strung out,
but I had guys driving up to me,
offering me $5 to fuck and shit.
And I was like,
"Yeah, sure, okay,"
get in the car,
take the $5, get out.
Shit like that.
This place is very cheap.
- [Mark] Where would you like
to see yourself in five years?
- [TJ] I always wanted to be a mom,
a stay at home mom,
but a good mom.
I always wanted to be better than my mom,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't see myself here.
- [Mark] Yeah, well, you're
still young and beautiful,
you could make that happen.
- [TJ] I mean, if I
don't end up doing that,
I'll probably be dead,
because the dope.
- [Mark] Look around at some of the women
that are older that have been here.
- Yeah, but some of them,
you look around and they look older,
but they're really not.
- [Mark] Well, that's what I'm saying,
that's what I'm saying.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You hang out here long enough,
eventually it takes a toll.
- Yeah, because sometimes I can't get up
because my back's hurting
and my knees are hurting
and shit like that,
I ain't never felt that,
I've been doing dope for seven years.
This dope is bad down here.
It's giving me holes in my skin and shit,
it's weird, but.
- [Mark] Is it heroin
that makes your skin.
- Yeah, yeah, it's the heroin.
And now they got fentanyl,
and that's what my mom and
my brother died off of,
my big brother.
- [Mark] Is there fentanyl in
the heroin that you're doing?
- Yeah, because they,
and it's everywhere,
you can't even get a batch of
heroin without fentanyl in it.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right.
- Yeah, they got test strips
down at the needle exchange,
you put it in the cooker
when you're done cooking up.
You just stick it in there
and it'll tell you how
much fentanyl's in it.
- [Mark] Oh right.
- Yeah, pretty much.
Shit.
I don't even know what else to say.
I got more to say,
but it's gotta be,
I have more to say,
but I've got a problem with,
I bounce back and forward from
different parts of my life
because stuff just comes up, oh,
like this happened and that happened,
because that's what really happened.
But it don't make sense
because I go from 12 to
18 to 15 years old and,
you know what I mean?
I guess that's just my ADD.
But I don't know.
I think probably living in the projects
was the hardest when I was growing up
because my mom was really
bad drinking there,
and drinking,
and that's when all the
guys would come over
and shit like that,
that's when they all
started first coming over.
So and my mom would,
I'd have to get my brother up for school,
I'd miss my bus usually.
My mom cracked three of my
ribs one time kicking me
because I kicked my bus one time
so she had to get up
and take me to school.
And that's when children
services started coming in,
but I'd always clean
the house up real quick,
do you know what I mean? And
so we wouldn't get taken away.
But I ended up getting taken away anyways
because I was a bad kid, I guess.
And I got put in 21
different foster homes,
I was in and out of juvie.
- [Mark] What age were
you when you left home?
- 14, yeah.
Yeah, my brother got to stay with his dad,
and I got put in the system, so.
- [Mark] Did you go to jail?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- [Mark] How many times?
- I can't even tell you, too many.
- [Mark] What's the hardest
part about living down here?
- Hardest part,
probably the bullshit that
you go through with the men.
Probably that, probably
because everybody wants,
you know what I mean?
If you're white and you're cute,
everybody wants a part of you,
a piece of you, everybody wants.
"TJ, TJ, hey, over here."
It doesn't matter how many
times I've seen them a day,
it doesn't matter if I've been
at their tent for two hours,
you know what I mean,
they're still yelling my name
if I fucking just leave their tent.
It's crazy.
- [Mark] You've had
some crazy stuff happen
with guys that pick you up?
- Yeah.
Twice, one time,
this guy picked me up in his truck
and he chocked me out
and he raped me or whatever.
But the crazy part was
was he kept passing by the tent everyday
and he'd just wave at me,
me and my dude. My dude, I
didn't tell my dude who he was
because I don't know
why I didn't tell him.
But I told him afterwards,
after we moved somewhere else,
but that was fucked up
because I'd see him everyday afterwards,
do you know what I mean? Because
he made sure I'd see him.
The hardest thing that
probably ever happened to me
was when I got kidnapped in Ohio
because I was fighting with
my boyfriend at the time
and it was an alcohol date,
and I don't usually do alcohols,
which means you go,
you leave your spot to go to their spot.
But I did because I was
mad at my boyfriend,
and I was texting him while
I was getting in the car
and everything like that.
And so, I wasn't paying
attention to the guy driving,
and we started going out the parking lot,
my boyfriend even crossed
past us and was like,
"What are you doing?
"Where are you going?"
And I was like, "Fuck you," whatever.
Well, an hour away,
the dude was like,
"Oh, by the way, "we can't
go to my house anymore,
"my roommate's there."
And started taking me to the woods.
So then I say to my boyfriend,
I was like, "Okay,
"something's going on,
"I'm going to the woods now."
And he started calling,
and the dude grabbed my cellphone
and smashed it up against the windshield
so the battery fell out.
(siren wailing)
You hear that all day long.
- [Mark] All night long.
- All night long.
So anyways, when I tried
to jump out the car,
he jumped on top of me
and he punched me and
dragged me back into the car.
And he did whatever,
I mean, he did whatever,
and then dropped me off at Arby's
and texted me and said,
"Hope you learned from
our talk that we had."
And somebody paid for a
taxi from Lima to Finley,
which is an hour and 45 minutes away,
so I can get back home.
And that was the end of that,
but that's probably the hardest,
only because I knew my boyfriend,
I thought I was gonna die.
I'm smiling because I
don't know what else to do,
but yeah,
I thought I was gonna die.
That's the only time I really
thought I was gonna die.
I mean, there's been a couple of times
when I've been close to death,
but there's something about me
where I always get out of stuff.
I don't know what it is.
Everybody will tell you that.
Yeah, I get myself into situations.
- [Mark] It's easy out here.
- Yeah.
I don't know what else to say.
- [Mark] That's all right, TJ,
thank you very much for talking to me.
- Okay, you're welcome.
- Appreciate it.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- All right.